I held it in till I was about
. you never told anybody
no I was you know because you got the
whole you know you say anything to kill
your parent thing the guys told you that
yeah started off with his kids first
doing it to me and then
of course they learned it from somewhere
and then uh
United's never and then by then by the
time I got a certain age at least amount
of people making fun of me or just
I felt like I was less of a man if I
said something because I just kept it to
myself it stays in the closet yeah I
didn't know it was gonna create so much
internal issues
but once I went through the addiction
thing and I put myself in therapy
finally released and I realized a lot of
that [__] was thin everything stems from
that from the abuse yeah where'd you
grow up Bakersfield California
Bakersfield yeah you had mom and dad
I had my mom and dad kind of
my uh father was uh always there they
got divorced and I was seven
and then uh
they uh did a joint not joint custody
they went to court
granted mom more time but she wasn't
really there for us
but my dad always
did everything he could for us that was
your mom not there for you uh his mom
she was young at the time man she um
well now that I know what's going on she
was young three kids and she started
Life to Live you know
I think when you're that age you just
wanna
you're not really sure how to do
anything you just go for it you know so
yeah that's where Mom was mom was
out all the time and I'll be back by
this time and that that time comes and
mom's still in that bag so
that was kind of weird
they just get used to it after a while
and then my dad we would go with my pops
they were switched like Monday through
Wednesday they were with my dad and
you know school had to be on schoolwork
had to be on the table for checking
no clothes had to be ironed which I
still do to this day because my dad you
know but my dad was
he did his best man but my dad was a
very angry person too
I mean
your wife
sleeps with your friends but you're at
work you know my dad worked a full-time
job two full-time jobs while going to
college
and having three kids
and then they get divorced because your
wife was sleeping with your friends it's
like
I can't imagine what he was going
through on the inside but
you know you ask a question and
everything was what just yelling and
[__] you know
so I didn't start talking until I was
about 16 because everything went on it's
just
I don't know I always had this like
feeling of being shocked or something
[Music]
like I was there my parents got when he
found out everything
yelling those put a fear in me man to
this day like
I get nervous thinking about [__] now I
just just to hear yelling and I get
like I lose control over myself and [__]
when I was younger I used to piss myself
because I used to be so [__] scared I
don't know why
being yelled at is scary for a kid yeah
and then it was always you know come
here I'm sorry and [__] but
I don't know I think as a kid man I just
my brother was very vocal my sister was
she was a daddy's girl so she was
protected but it was just me I've always
felt like
nobody heard me and nobody cared enough
to ask if I was okay and [__] you know
but
you know I had to start because I was a
middle child middle child always gets
screwed at some point
so they see in the movies right
but life just happened that way you know
and the mom
started bringing around multiple men and
it was just weird because none of these
men are my father
and I'm gonna go home my dad would ask
if I was okay
by then I wouldn't talk everything was
just
nodding and [__]
you know and then
over the years mom would just introduce
different men different men some of them
were okay
some men like I still keep in contact
with him and all of his buddies because
they're like uncles than me but then
there's some men they just
I wonder what God was thinking when he
made them you know
abuse start the section when I was a kid
it
was about nine years old the first time
it happened who was I with
I was by myself we were at the mom took
us to a party
and I was playing with the kids and all
that we're I was in the closet hey
playing with them you know and then
when did the daughters started
uh she took her clothes off I was like
you need to know when something isn't
normal you could just feel it in your
stomach and then again I got that
shocking feeling that I couldn't do
anything filling
and then she started uh touching me in
certain areas you know
I remember leaving it was like this
isn't
I wasn't right
but I was so [__] scared because I
was like what if they don't believe me
you know what if something like
I don't want them to think I was doing
that [__]
and they go to parties man and ask the
same people I was just like
it should bring her little friend to do
it and it was just like what the [__]
man
it's a kid you know
I got my first [__] when I was nine
years old from this little girl like
where did you who taught you this [__]
man
and later I learned where she learned
all that from
you know men and
his wife they would
do the same thing and
like
sorry I
stuck my second time talking about this
and so
it didn't end there
yeah
I wish it did but it did it you know I
mean
good
I remember after that everybody was
outside
[__] why can't nobody's coming to see if
I'm okay in a wedding to come look for
me I was
I started thinking like man what the
[__] where in the hell is my
where's my mom
she has to come I know and mom never
came and it was
and then they took me in the kitchen
they turned the stove on they put you
know and they got my hand and I'm like
they were trying to put it on there I
was like so I'm [__] pulling it back
and they're like well if you say
anything this you're gonna go in the
fire
we're gonna kill your parents and
they'll say [__] you know when you're a
kid you believe everything everybody
says
you know it was just
and that feeling of being like that
shocking feeling man it stood there
years on then man and then
time to go to a party and [__] we would
see these [__] people what happened
get a little get together you know and
I never said anything because I know how
my dad's side of the family is and
never wanted I didn't want my parents to
die
but I grew a hatred for my mother
and I was just like
and then I'm gonna go home like maybe I
could tell my dad when he picked us up
but my dad was so angry at the world
like I don't want to make it more mad
and [__] you know
but my dad I know my dad loves us you
know
people just have a different way of
showing it and
over the years this guy
like he was my dad was just going
through his own [__] you know
but I've always loved my dad my dad
always loved me you know I'm a daddy's
boy man
I've always been there
School the whole night but Dad was there
but it was just like how do I tell my
dad this [__] is happening
and I try not to live a life with regret
man but
it's probably one of the biggest regrets
I have never said anything
um
after a certain age all that [__] stops
though
because you
can only beat something so much you you
do something you know
[__]
but then 12 like 12 years old came
around and
my brother starts coming around and like
we've always been I've always seen my
brother you know but this time my
brother he had hair like me and
everything that he came home with the
shaved head and the cut in his eyebrow
and
a big t-shirt and all that [__] and he's
talking and he's teaching me that I was
like what what is that
oh you're running with those guys now
you know and he's teaching me like
the way everything he was doing you know
smoking weed and all that [__] and all
that
but I noticed with the weed smoke
that shocking feeling was gone I was
like oh [__] I like that
and my brother he would go out but it
was just like he can't go anywhere
unless you take your brother with you
and then we're hanging out with his
buddies and
I'm thinking they're really doing [__]
out in the street but then it's like
my brother's doing it then it must be
okay
nobody's telling him nothing
you get involved with people man and
I started meeting other people and
it was just weird because I would hang
out with all these gangsters and [__]
like that but then I would go home and
I would just cut myself
nose
and then a family just fighting the you
know my mom is taking my dad to court
every chance she should get and
we have to go to mediation they'll make
us pick up pick who he wanted to stay
with I'm like I don't want to stay my
mom
she's never there
that I want to go back I'm scared of
that [__] place man I'm scared of
like what I should meet somebody else
and they'd start doing that [__] and it
starts over
you know and
she would just leave and she would never
come back and
she would come back but it was just like
she wasn't being a mom and
I just wanted my mom to love me and I
didn't feel that [__] at all man and
they started to feel angry and then
I'm gonna go see my grandparents my
grandparents are the greatest people in
the world Manning
that feeling my grandmother gave me I
wanted that from my mom but I knew even
at a young age that [__] wasn't gonna
happen
I am
people are [__] up Mark
oven
it's shocking how common this is
yeah and I always thought it was just me
going through that [__] you know I
apologize for cutting so much it sounds
ugly
um
I never told nobody man and
started doing things in the streets and
one day I'm Nicholas I'm Bubba and then
now on virus see Loco
and I go I'm 30 years old so I came up
and like you had to earn your name and
your name
presented you you know
and I started doing a lot of [__] up
[__] out there man and
now meet kids at school and they're
coming to school with weed and
their parents mess and pills I'm like
what the [__] is all this guy I've never
seen any of that before and then
I started hanging out more and more with
these people because I felt
at the time I thought it was what I was
missing you know
something
isn't right I just felt it all my whole
life like something was off
you know and
there was no connection in there with
anybody
even at home
my dad's family is they're great people
man they're totally opposite of
at the time they [__] love in the
family man they cared for everything and
but I still felt like because of what
happened to me like
I didn't have the love
you know
then I would go out and
I'm like [__] I'm gonna go try Sports
out and my dad would
I never played a [__] down a football
in my life when I went to go play
that was terrible
it's like maybe my mom would come see me
play you know maybe she'll see me in a
jersey and support me and [__] and
my mom never came
and I will I didn't play one down in
flag football and I
I would look up and
it was my dad
in his work uniforms my dad was a
probation officer at the time you know
and
he would take time off work to come see
me
and I appreciated that so much I know he
would always be there but I was like I
mean my mom would come
and I would call her like
even come to my game well I didn't know
about it nobody told me nothing but I'm
like
I gave you the schedule
you want to come
but she would go out like a [__]
though you know
in the days we were with her you know
she would
our clothes would be [__] up man and
my shoes would be [__] up and her
nails were done her hair was done
he's a new man a new purse
he had time for that but
might be trying him
mom wasn't there and then
my birthday would come you know and
because my brother and sister it was
it was a big event for them but it was
me
I made my mama come with Tony happy
birthday you know and
the phone never rang man it was just and
my dad would hug me and he'll be like
I'm sorry son but
you know
and then made me more angry and more
angry man I started doing more [__] and
High School comes around I started
taking uh
prescription pills and
I had my first Vicodin for the first
time
just that one little vacant it took
everything that I felt right here
it was gone
but even then I knew
something wasn't right with that [__]
there's no way this is
happening
this one thing is take all that pain
away man and
I got addicted to that [__]
not bad but I knew like if I didn't have
it I would
I started noticing my mood swings and
all that [__] so I started
I started selling and everything in
school and
it's just weird but
after a while all those feelings came
back
and then uh
so much more just happened man this life
just happened and
when I was 17 I
I was out
and I see the duties do that [__] to me
huh
by then I'm
I'm a teenager that's filled with anger
you can't tell me nothing
I don't talk at all I'm going to family
functions
I had my air my uh airpod in my uh
on my airpods my earbuds at the time no
and let's listen to music
music has always calming down so I
wouldn't talk to anybody
family functions nothing
so when I see dude it was just like
you know
and I approach him and he sees me coming
to have my buddies with me and I tell
them to wait right here and
it becomes a little girl as he had at
the time they're my age now
or around there
but they knew
I wasn't coming to say hi
that's funny
you know you hear in movies and hearing
things that street Justice isn't a good
thing but at that time the feelings I
had
I thought I became a man at that point
I left not the feeling
like I fixed anything nothing went away
would you do
well the gun had 10 bolts and they came
back I had seven left
I was a kid
being hurt by this person
[Music]
I didn't kill him
I should have
I don't know man just
did I do the right thing you know
here I am
feeling a certain way because somebody
did something to me and I'm doing
something back that doesn't make a right
but when you're going to trauma
and you don't know from right from wrong
like that when you're dealing with
feelings
you know give a [__] at certain points
you know
and my buddies coming like
the [__] you doing
in that shocking feeling game
and knowing
didn't make me feel better mark
no
time it did
I didn't cry I didn't
I didn't feel anywhere after that
because I was
already doing what I was doing to get
rid of the pain and [__]
now I uh
but maybe if I did that then
my mom will come
[Music]
and she would
maybe I should see me you know
she's she sees everybody else
nah
that's her in 18 and
everything I was doing I started seeing
faces I was going to sleep and
just felt like I couldn't take that [__]
anymore so
you ended up hanging myself and
it's like I couldn't even do that right
the cord snaps and
I tell my high school teacher like this
is what happened
and that she reported me to the
counselor and
they got me some help but that [__]
they say it's hell but they ain't doing
nothing
[Music]
they started doing things man like life
wasn't always bad but when it gets bad
it gets bad
I try to
make sense of everything that happened
you know
graduate from high school and it was
just like now what
nothing changed I still felt the way I
felt
and I started to feel like
everything I was doing was for nothing
because at that point
now that what I know now is just like
I'm just looking for somebody to care
for me you know
I want that Mother's Love that I never
had
I don't know just
just angry all the time and
I would lash out I would my friends
would call like yo this is happening and
I would be there I would go
because I didn't care if I lived or died
I didn't care what happened
I was always there
it just I don't know man which is so
[__] weird life is weird man
like what did I do to deserve this [__]
but then it's like
and then he grew up with certain people
around you and they're like you got a
man up
can't show no feelings what are you a
[__] yes
so now you're fighting because somebody
called you out of name rather just
talking and [__] but nobody knows at
that point
especially when you come from areas that
you don't have time to be sad or time to
be vulnerable and all that
that's always been my biggest thing Matt
I had a
I have a fear of being vulnerable you
know
so that causes me to act out was
aggression and
I've always cared about people man I've
always
I always wanted friends you know
I would try and
we'll come and then they will leave
she's going through life you feel like
nobody understands you and [__] you know
and I'm doing all kinds of wild [__] and
there's like he just wants attention and
all that and he just
want somebody to care about me you know
like I know my dad cares about me and
his family cares I have everybody cares
my family
I don't feel that [__]
and I'm so used to being abandoned and
[__]
and to me I think it's normal and that
[__] ain't normal
supposed to have compassion for others
and who am I to talk about we were doing
stupid [__]
and this life just goes on and it gets
dark
spend a lot of time alone man
was lonely
when I was a kid I would just just be in
my room
and we were constantly moved so
and I didn't talk to you there's no way
I was going to make a friend that way
so movies became my friend
to the point where I could recite every
damn movie I watched
and I don't I want to hang out my
brother and sister but they're like no
we don't want to go over there we want
to stay over here and
and when we were all together they never
wanted to hang out like that because
they were you know everybody has their
own personality at that point everybody
has things they're interested in
let's put a lot of time alone mark
more than I should have so
living like that I took the fear of
imprisonment away from me I think
but it also ruined my communication
skills and my social life my social
skills
I go out I don't
get that shocking feeling just want to
go home
go home just want to be out
it's like [__] I knew I was depressed
though
you know the courts they put us in like
counseling and all that [__] at a young
age and
[Music]
but I still rather it all happened to me
than to my brother and sister you know
I want nothing to happen in them
like even to this day I wish all the bad
would just happen to me because I don't
want them to ever feel
how I feel at night sometimes you know
20s to come that's him
I turned 20 I was like whoa
just maneuver just going through a life
man and
22 came and
[__] legs give out for some reason
and learn to walk again
and look to my right
it's my dad
there again to build me out
just being there for me you know and
it took my license they took
took me off work and there I am home
alone again
and it felt like
felt like I was nuts man
and then the doctor prescribes me Norcos
and
back down the rabbit hole I guess
so [__] Dark Mark I didn't
at that point you're 20 years old you're
still doing the same [__] you're going
through the same [__] you don't think
anything is going to happen you know
Nothing's Gonna Change
I'm just doing things for people I
shouldn't be doing I'm putting my
freedom at risk for people now I know
they don't give a damn about me
people are my friends they get in
trouble they call me up and like a
[__] idiot there I go
then my 20s the mid-20s
life
and then fentanyl hits Bakersfield and
that [__] was no joke
I didn't know it was fitting all the
time I just ran out of my prescriptions
for my legs my legs [__] hurt all the
time
I was walking with a cane for a while
and then I found these things and
people say they're possessed on drugs
and [__]
that's what that is man
I got to a point where I was snorting
the 15 to 20 pills a day
and I'm thinking nobody knows you know
I've always been wanting to cut my hair
I've always been one to iron my shirt
every day because that's what my dad
showed me as a kid and
I didn't cut my hair for a long time and
lost a shitload of weight and
you know I lived with my brother at the
time and he came home one day and he
yelled at me I let nobody to this day
I'll let nobody yell at me
because I don't want that shocking
feeling you know
he's gave me an ultimatum you get your
[__] right
or we're not going to be brothers
anymore then
we have a childhood friend he told me
the same thing he's a big old dude he
thought you're a hype mark
big old dude
he's never yelled at me before ever
you know when somebody yells at you
though it's like in a certain way that
you can you know what they're saying is
the truth ain't no lie in them
and then my dad and his new wife came
and dad didn't yell at me
it's a really debate you let me know he
wasn't giving up on me they both did
my stepmom I don't call her step that's
my mom
she took that lady's place and
they got me help and I knew like this
was it this is my last chance that
fixing everything this is
this is the end of the row either you go
this way
so there you go how much uh I went to
rehab and uh
that withdrawal State man that [__] was
I never knew about where Charles because
I was always I got everything I was
getting this [__] from my buddy and
it was an endless amount
but man that [__] throw withdrawals
I'm not a I'm not a tough guy at all
that [__] right there man you gotta have
your balls screwed on tight for that
[__]
and I get to the rehab place and the
detox center oh the detox floor
uh there was a covet outbreak so they
shut it down so they started putting
people going for detox they put them
into mental health ward
and some of those people are from County
Jail getting observation and [__]
and they're trying to run the unit like
it's a prison
and I'm no stranger to
fighting
being aggressive
so there I'm [__] withdrawing mark
and these dudes come in trying to run
this [__] like a prison
so they gave us little toothbrushes to
brush our teeth and they let us go
outside to play with chalk like we're
kids I keep forgetting we're in the
mental ward some of these people are
kids they're fully grown but they're
kids
I took a toothbrush out there I mean I
put it under a chalk
and I just started going back and forth
on the floor and they're thinking I'm
just making a mess with the chop
but I'm really sharpening the [__]
toothbrush at the bottom
I'm scared
and these dudes just Grace tattoo
because
a lot of them my age are a little bit
older and
not the kids now and they you have a
tattoo on your face you're just
you could be anybody
but you can tell these guys got them
when they meant something
and they're stealing people's snacks
they're going around smacking people and
I was like oh no
so I got to put that withdrawal [__] I
gotta put that to the side
dude comes in and we get it in
I'm not gonna let nobody put their hands
on me so I just take off first I have
nothing to lose at this point
I've been doing [__] fentanyl for
about a year straight
I'm snorting pills everything I had went
into that [__]
but just doing that one thing
to set the record that let everybody
know like what nobody gonna touch me
then I go back in my room and I start
crying man
so I don't want to be harmed
that shock feeling came back
and they start crying man like
what the [__] am I doing
I'm tired
like mentally exhausted and [__] you
know and
I call home and dad's there again
you know call my brother and he's
supportive you know I call my sister
she's supportive I call some of my uncle
they're supportive
I started thinking man I've been chasing
my mother's love this whole time
it's no reason I had everything I needed
right here
they love me [__] them
you don't love me [__] you you know
and then my last day we um
a program director came in and they were
like
I need some therapy
because you've got little group sessions
like yeah you need some therapy in here
and I knew this is my last chance to get
it right this is what I need to fix
myself
so I agreed and
I come home and
realize a mess I created
I'm over here ruining my life because
somebody hurt me from
it wasn't my fault
you know and
and everything you're just eating me up
on the inside because I never told
anybody anything
from the child [__] the street [__] that
I've always done everything by myself
you know
when they did what I did a dude my
buddies just happened to be there but
I've always made in my business and
never had nobody around me when I do
certain [__]
it's all one road
you started merging and all that [__]
that's what they need to get [__] up
start going to therapy I meet this woman
Valerie
she's a therapist there
then I meet Randy and they they start
giving me papers about
assertiveness and passive aggression and
all that never heard of any of this [__]
and we start uh
stand for processing how you feel that
day
and everybody is just there is there
look at his tailored is there to kill
time we're just there because they're
appointed to and
I was there to get help man and
every day was always a little more push
a little more push but I wouldn't talk
and they needed an answer because it was
a group therapy thing
so when I got I've always sat next to
her because I knew I had to trust
somebody in this room that was the only
way it was going to work
I trusted more Valerie
and the whole time she's getting the
answers out of me and I didn't know I
was giving her the keys to the locks and
my
mental you know
and she got in and she uh
she broke me down but she built me back
up
she replaced all that darkness in me
with some with hope
her and Randy the program director of
Nolan they're building me up and they're
building me up man and it's
and they're supplying me what the tools
I need to fix the things in my house if
they ever break on the inside
and I start feeling
happiness
and I start meditating I start listening
to uh
a lot of pianos man and
people tell me you should listen to
Kevin Gates
you reminds me of you and I never heard
any of his music and
never met that person man but we clicked
the music is just everything he's saying
I could feel that [__]
and Man by the end of that program it's
a three-month program
I went in there mad I had a hoodie on I
wouldn't talk to anybody but when I got
out males making jokes
you know I'm smiling for the first time
people see it you know they're like
you're different now
you know I started meditating and I
started doing everything on that
pamphlet they gave you and I applied it
to my everyday life you know
and I started feeling happiness and
started
I took up
because I was never big on religion
thought I was
and then I started learning about the
Muslim religion and all that I was like
man this [__] works and then
I started fasting
and it's working you know I
start to feel this feeling manages
happiness I'm so [__] happy
I gotta even want to go to bed because I
wanted I didn't want to miss out on the
happiness but
then I want to go to bed because I'm
gonna wake up and feel the same way
tomorrow so I'm there you know
and it's there now it's with all that
[__] man in his
I found the happiness I've always been
looking for was what did me the whole
time
you know then that came across your
Channel
and I hear a marriage little story damn
she been through it
and then
Here Comes sharp you know and he's
you know
you say transform yourself
it's a gift we all have but we lose it
you gotta go find that [__] that's what
makes you strong it was like man this
guy's talking that [__]
you know that I meet I see other people
man and I think about the Whitakers you
know everybody on your channel I'm like
everybody goes through something man
it's not just me
so that made it easier tonight
it wasn't okay what happened to me but
it made it easier to process you know
and then I see my mom
and I'm
if you go two ways that can be a dick
everything
where I can use what I've been learning
I could change something you know
and I start thinking about everything
I've been through as a kid as a teenager
earlier an adult
and I started thinking about here I
can't pick sides anymore
I can't go through life blaming people
you know holding that guilt because I'm
learning this it's all trauma
people only doing what they know how to
do you gotta let people be who they are
gotta accept my mother for who she is
not what she is
because she's just learning what she was
taught
she didn't know what she was doing with
three kids
but what parent does you know
tell her like hey let's go eat
let's go have dinner or something
to get in the car the first thing first
I want to talk about nothing from the
past I forgive you for everything
so I'm still learning about
self-accountability and
self-reflection
and now I'm still spending a lot of time
at home
I'm lonely anymore I'm just alone and
that's okay
because I learned to love myself man
and learn to be okay with who I am ain't
nothing wrong with me
I'm one of the greatest things that ever
happened in people's lives man that's
how I feel
so I can go through a lot of [__] cause
people been way too way more [__] than I
have
but I choose not to live in the darkness
anymore you know
you listen to music like man I gotta
meet Kevin one day you know
I want one of these
Breadwinner chain you know because I
feel like I went through all that
adversity counts that
I feel like I'm on a chain you know but
then I'm like
I live in reality here and it
and I told myself like I'm not a virus
anymore I'm just Nicholas
I'm happy
I'm peaceful I just want everybody to
feel the way I feel
you know my family and my family hate
each other man
try to get together for the holidays and
you can just feel that tension walk in
there you can just cut it with a knife
man it's just like well [__] what you
guys are doing because this is what
we're doing it's me and my brother my
sister man we we call each other that
you know what happened we don't we don't
care
we're gonna do our own thing man we're
gonna be happy we ain't gonna let nobody
[__] with that no more
and that's what happened man hey
if Valerie did something to me
and I tell her like I told her and Randy
all the years of school when you guys
had
all those hard nights you guys had
no I know college is hard
it was all worth it
because you help you're gonna help
somebody
and you help me
one person is more than enough
you know
I lost all my friends in the process of
all this man they cut me off
at first I was at a denial you know
I didn't have a lot of friends but the
ones that
they were there and you know I was in
the Attic
doing the attic [__]
you know I never judged them for
anything they did they can get drunk and
all that [__] and I would still be there
they will call me something bad happened
I put my freedom at risk you know
I take a few pills and I'm the bad
person that's fine
I've always rooted for the villain in
the movies anyway you know sometimes
they make it sometimes they know
I'm fine with flipping the coin on that
you don't want to be around me I'm not
going to beg you
you know you don't want to be my friend
you don't want to be associated with me
that's fine because I have me at the end
of the day I know what it took to get to
where I'm at today
I'm never gonna let nobody [__] that up
again
you know
I'm happy
It's All About Me
you know I gave up a long time ago man I
didn't know why but
that thing that's inside of you man
that's me
that pounding
that's another chance at life
it's another opportunity that's hope
that's everything you ever wanted
and you gotta find that [__] man you
gotta go for it you know
and I found it
I know
my family's probably going to see this
[__] they're gonna be like what the [__]
they're gonna call they're gonna ask all
type of questions I don't have no
answers for you so don't even try it
it's too late for the answer
to make for the questions I mean you
know
but I'm okay
because I have this beating inside of me
as long as I have that it's enough to
get me out of bed
you have to keep me going I'm two years
sober two years six months sober
you know I don't have the best job but I
got a job only you're 30 years old man
all this [__] started when I was
nine
they got divorced at seven
but nine years old when it really took
off Got Deep
and I'm 30.
took a while yeah plenty of years yeah
plenty of years man but
that [__] beating in me
I'm fly
that's how I feel the more I look in the
mirror and I can't be [__] with Mark
I'm happy to Smiley right up and put me
in the cave and I like that [__] up you
know what I mean I'm happy man I feel
amazing you know I don't have the most
money I'd be struggling sometimes man
but
[__] it Life's a struggle from what I've
been through and now bring that [__] up
you know I'm here man I'm flying up in
the air with it you know I mean I got
these big old Wings on me you know
this [__] cool man I appreciate you for
having me mark thank the story thanks
man thank you man yeah